[Musica]
[Applauso]
tocchiamo il nostro smartphone il nostro
telefono intelligente almeno 2.600 volte
al giorno
questo è pura perché dicono le ultime
statistiche sulla media in italia è
diventata una vera e propria estensione
del nostro corpo
anche quando lo teniamo in tasca io mi
chiamo come di gioco per tutte le
occasioni ci facciamo i santi ricordiamo
tra l'altro ma anche lo usiamo per
condividere immagini su tutto quello che
facciamo anche della pizza che ci
troveranno davanti al ristorante e la
dopamina che si producono ilike dei
nostri amici digitali ci basti dire che
lì ci siamo capiti anche di essere
condivide di essere collegati con una
moltitudine
certe volte lo facciamo anche senza far
sapere che siamo noi veramente ma le
reti di gil eventi sociali ai motori di
ricerca
sì ci isola tosti in una mostra in cui
spartiamo opinioni e idee isolamenti con
quelli tra pensano come noi e per cui ti
mettiamo aggressivi verso gli altri
anche perché l'uso intensivo delle reti
digitali fa aumentare gli ormoni dello
stress il cortisolo e l'adrenalina
mettere diminuiti diminuiscono la
tranquillizzante ossitocina forse per
questo aumenta la litigiosità politica
nel mondo digitale e di cecità che poi
portiamo anche nel mondo reale
quel regredendo qualche modo dal
villaggio globale ai villaggi tribali
però questa volta gestiti dalle reti in
qualche modo siamo diventati una un
primate con un codice a barre un codice
a barre che codifica la relazione tra i
nostri comportamenti e le nostre
emozioni e le macchine intelligenti così
chiamano le sapete cosa mi riferisco
riescono a leggere questo codice a barre
e possono controllarci
e anche condizionarci questo uomo
sapiens che ha fotografato sulla
spiaggia di bondi beach non avesse un
problema a mostrare soprani chabal e ma
quando da quando siamo in questa
situazione
beh se andiamo le origini della nostra
vita e come specie homo sapiens allora
non avevamo molti condizionamenti
eravamo liberi
ognuno andava e va in una direzione che
avevamo insieme
e stato prima e ai doriani altre specie
umane con cui felicemente ci accoppiamo
e ci incrociavamo vuoi un certo punto
siamo rimasti solo noi l'homo sapiens
trasformati in un organismo che possiamo
descrivere sempre con codice a barre in
cui per ogni individuo è solo una barra
da quando siamo diventati questo codice
amare questo organismo sociale complessa
e sembra che 100 mila anni fa ci siamo
abbiamo siamo stati selezionati per
ridurre la nostra aggressività
individuale per formare organismi
sociali sempre più estese in pratica ci
siamo auto addomesticati e come lo
sappiamo lo sappiamo anche studiando ad
altri animali che si auto addomesticano
per esempio gli antenati dei nostri
cagnolini i lupi 20 o 30 mila anni fa
alcuni gruppi di lupi hanno ridotto la
loro aggressività per potere vivere
senza troppi stress nelle vicinanze
homo sapiens possiamo piena era glaciale
per usufruire di una nuova nicchia
ecologica che era antonio il cibo i
sapiens che allora ci deve a grandi e
rimani presente come il maruggio nelle
steppe euroasiatiche si sono studiate
anche altri animali in situazioni più
controllate per è vecchio è un
esperimento che ha iniziato ai tempi
dell'unione sovietica nonno sapiens e
siberia dove sono addomesticate le mogli
selvagge e lì sono partite da 300 colpi
selvagge della siberia e attraverso
molte generazioni hanno selezionato
quelle meno aggressive o in accoppiando
le tra di loro
alla fine avete dei cagnolini se voi
andate in questo laboratorio che
potrebbe essere un'interessante
esperienza
bisogna trovarli che sophie le date dei
cagnolini sono diventate più mingherline
la testa più piccola in uso in corto lo
stesso in eccesso poi ai lunghi poi
quest'anno domestic abili quindi una
quella che si chiama sindrome da
domesticazione che agisce sia sulla
parte anatomica anche genetica che
ormonale questo viene questo processo in
trasformazione questa metamorfosi
avviene attraverso un processo molto
semplice che si chiama mente mia c'è
bisogna estendere la fase giovanile
durante tutta la vita adulta i pad i
nostri cani si comportano come dei lupi
che sono che sono ancora in fase stato
infantile e lo stesso le volti per cui
c'è un maggior aumento
in seguito a questa a questo processo
c'è un maggior aumento non solo della
socialità cioè c'è meno stress a stare
insieme di altre come nel caso umano tra
l'altro anche nell'uomo c'è una
trasformazione se vede gli uomini di
precedenti e la confrontati con noi
veneti che noi abbiamo un
abbiamo un una falsa più piccola molto
più piccola dei neanderthal e di tutti
gli altri umani precederli abbiamo anche
una testa molto più rotondo e siamo più
mingherlini comunque assieme alla
socialità degli animali aki noi aumenta
la propensione al gioco di cui abbiamo
parlato molto anche gli interventi
precedenti e anche alle attività
sessuali
per divertimento in generale quindi sia
noi che i lupi che queste volti nelle
loro gabbie siamo andati attraverso
questa è proprio questo processo e
abbiamo avuto questa chiamava la
malattia questa sindrome da auto
addomesticazione quindi questi homo
sapiens che si stavano alto domesticato
durante l'era glaciale vivevano come un
organico non ha un gruppo sociale in cui
già si era stabilita una dipendenza di
ogni di punti e di dubbi rispetto ad
altri
e c'è anche la disuguaglianza per
mantenere questo ordine si può usare la
forza queste società umane del fare all
etico
parliamo del periodo durante l'ultima né
glaciale molto prima delle grandi
civiltà e dell'agricoltura di cui
parlava mosca parimenti madre per
mantenere questo ordine bisognerebbe
bisogna anche lavorare sulla
fascinazione
ecco che diventano importanti dei riti
particolari che fanno che mettono in
funzione i nostri in euro attivatori del
piacere della ricompensa basati su anche
su cerimonia in cui c'è musica v vi
mostro il più antico flauto trovato in
germania del paleolitico di 43 mila anni
fa piena era glaciale
poi se va detto che a quanto dicevo
prima per quanto riguarda la il gioco e
le attività sessuali come importanza
dell'auto domesticato vedete queste
anche queste veneri di iper sessuate
sono di questo periodo e 43 mila anni fa
in germania cui bisogna usare simboli e
rappresentazioni del proprio corpo e
rappresentazione anche dell'ambiente
quindi simboli e immagini diventano
importante allora senti io per esempio
venivano fatti mettendo una mano sopra
la roccia e sputandoci sopra un liquido
a base di droga e acqua è l'ora degli
rimaneva la sagoma è l'amara vengono
trovate nel paleolitico superiore
molte rocce con queste nostre mani oltre
naturalmente alle meravigliose immagini
che vediamo che sono quelli della grotta
delle grotte in francia
l'ambiente nell'accogliere sociale
guideranno accelerava questa auto
addomesticazione perché incominciavano a
partire da dividere il nostro lavoro con
gli altri c'è uno faceva delle cose un
po specialistiche purtroppo molto tempo
per dare i dettagli
abbiamo le prove che questo già iniziava
nel paleolitico superiore per cui
diventavamo appunto sempre più
dipendenti dagli altri e più non
giardini sembra anche ma questi dati
devono essere ancora confermati che il
nostro cervello incominciasse a ridursi
come come dimensioni e come massa tanto
penso che oggi si assume già che il
nostro cervello pesa oggi circa 100
grammi meno il cervello dei nostri
antenati del paleolitico superiore
quindi noi andiamo in media
un cervello da un chilo 13 quote anche
questo è un effetto della auto
domesticazione quindi dove siamo
arrivati poi oggi con questo processo
beh oggi questo gioco proprio questo
grande gioco nella nostra società è
gestito attraverso le macchine
intelligenti negli arredi algoritmi e vi
posso solo dare un esempio di quello che
sta iniziando adesso in cina dove è
stato istituito un programma di credito
sociale in cui vengono assegnati dei
punti a tutte le persone e questi punti
e poi si viene puniti se i punti vanno
verso il verso lo zero e si viene
premiati se vanno verso il 100 mi pare
con 100 punti fermi se fate visse in
combinate più rock rasi con google in
cina magari perdete qualche punto per
che state cercando un polonio in rete i
dati vengono usati dp data che ognuno di
noi lascia nella rete dove ci muoviamo
appunto lasciamo questa scia di dati
come una lumaca che si muove nola ma
cantici tale che si muove nella rete
lasciamo questa scia degli algoritmi
posso d'individuare di costruire il
nostro comportamento ha poi usando anche
sistemi di ripresa visiva e aido ritmi
di ultima generazione
adesso si comincia a poter identificare
la nostra faccia per cui possiamo essere
seguiti anche del nostro del mondo nel
mondo fisico quindi per concludere nel
passato profondo abbiamo esteso il
nostro corpo come gli strumenti di tichy
e poi abbiamo connesso tutte le nostre
menti attraverso i simboli e
l'immaginazione come qualcuno ha già
menzionato ma alla fine siamo diventati
un organismo sociale molto complesso
fatto di bambini felici e auto domestic
ati e tornate di la mente mia quindi
oggi oggi dovrete dobbiamo capire qual è
il nostro rapporto con questo strumento
che vi ho da chevy o di cui parlavo
all'inizio con questo pezzo di
tecnologia intelligente che abbiamo al
tar di cui abbiamo che è disponibile
solamente da pochi anni ma il rapporto
che abbiamo con questo centro ha le
radici nel tempo molto profondo più di
50.000 mila anni fa ed è un
comportamento collegato con le emozioni
che però è assegnato il nostro dna
la nostra struttura ormonale e la nostra
psicologia e con questo dobbiamo fare i
conti
[Applauso]
[Musica]